[Musica]
[Applauso]
se dici che su Google la parola dati il
motore di ricerca americano ti
restituisce 16 miliardi di risultati un
numero enorme pari a 276 volte gli
abitanti dell'Italia
se invece facciamo un paragone con
qualcosa di più vicino a me che sono
genovese e digitiamo ad esempio la
parola pezzo Beh Google ci restituisce
185 milioni di risultati pari
all'incirca tre volte gli abitanti
dell'Italia tutto questo parlare di
numeri perché da quasi 10 anni il lavoro
come data Artist e Designer
dell'informazione il mio lavoro consiste
nel raccogliere dati e trasformarli
visivamente infatti e storie sulla base
di informazioni
come ad esempio raccogliere dati su
Excel e trasformarli in grafiche che
raccontano le specie cosiddette aliene
specie invasive che distruggono la
biodiversità dei nostri ambienti oppure
addirittura mappare la rete
sentieristica europea con i suoi oltre
60 km di strade percorribili a piedi
ma a volte questi dati ci raccontano
altre storie come ad esempio gli inni
nazionali di tutti i paesi del mondo
Io nella mia vita ho sempre raccolto
dati talvolta inconsciamente scattando
fotografie o magari scrivendo delle note
oppure invece registrando l'audio di
alcuni suoni per ricordarmi di
particolari momenti particolari emozioni
e negli anni ho creato un archivio un
archivio enorme di suoni di dati di
immagine di informazioni e alla fine di
questa sessione per i dati ne ho fatto
il mio lavoro
Ma i dati però sono un concetto un po'
astratto da spiegare quindi uso
un'analogia una metafora per me i dati
sono come una fotografia Questa è la
prima fotografia scattata al mondo del
1822 da uno scienziato francese e come
possiamo vedere non rappresenta la
realtà al 100%
. è una rappresentazione mediata dalla
tecnologia disponibile al tempo e dal
punto di vista di chi quella sta
fotografia la scattata Beh i dati più o
meno sono un po' la stessa cosa sono una
fotografia su una situazione su un
particolare fenomeno
mediata dalla tecnologia disponibile al
tempo per raccogliere questi dati
ovviamente ma soprattutto da chi questi
dati li ha raccolti dal proprio punto di
vista e questi dati sono ovunque secondo
uno studio di forbice del 2018 è stato
stimato che ogni giorno produciamo 2,5
quintilioni di byte di dati
che è un numero inimmaginabile un numero
30 Zeri Beh questi dati comprendono di
tutto dalle ricerche su Google
all'ultimo video caricato su Tik Tok e i
dati sono molto importanti perché noi
con i dati misuriamo tutto da i
risultati elettorali alla crescita
demografica di un paese da passare del
tempo agli anni dei nostri cari
addirittura le tasse sui nostri stipendi
e questi dati cosa sono sono ovviamente
numeri sono numeri percentuali frazioni
e possono essere comunicati usando dei
grafici delle tabelle ma a volte
addirittura sotto forma di vere e
proprie opere d'arte banalmente tutto
quello che possiamo quantificare con un
valore numerico e catalogare con delle
variabili è un dato e noi lo possiamo
rappresentare visivamente
Ora molti di voi penseranno solamente ad
Excel ma vorrei ricordarvi di questa
fotografia perché sempre più spesso i
dati rappresentano un punto di vista e
comunicano non solo fatti ma soprattutto
emozioni storie e persone
immaginatevi i dati come un paio di
occhiali che ci permettono di vedere
situazioni altrimenti impossibili da
osservare
però io ora vi dico un'altra cosa vi
dico che i dati non sono solo numeri
Ebbene sì perché ci sono altre tipologie
di dati come ad esempio immagini parole
addirittura suoni e la disciplina della
visualizzazione di dati ha un nome per
descrivere questa tipologia di dati li
Chiama qualitativi perché sono dati che
descrivono un argomento contrapposti a
quelli quantitativi che invece
L'argomento lo misurano usando appunto
numeri e cifre
quindi mi sono chiesta sarà mai
possibile visualizzare un'immagine o
addirittura visualizzare i dati
contenuti il suono legati a un suono
Beh guardate questa immagine qui per
molti non rappresenta assolutamente
nulla Un insieme di linee punti
un'immagine da usare come salvaschermo
per il proprio computer o per i più
adatti da appendere Addirittura in
salotto ora vi chiederei di chiudere gli
occhi e di ascoltare questo suono
questo suono l'ho registrato durante una
passeggiata in un parco di Londra la
città dove viveva e fa parte di
quell'archivio di suoni e di date che io
ho raccolto anche inconsciamente nel
corso della mia vita ora voi vi starete
chiedendo Beh ma cosa c'entra con
l'immagine di prima ma questa immagine è
una visualizzazione dei dati ma i dati
usati per creare questa immagine non
sono numeri bensì il suono che avete
appena ascoltato
quel suono è un dato e contiene
moltissime informazioni
Innanzitutto informazioni descrittive
come rumore delle foglie mosse dal vento
oppure le conversazioni dei passanti
tutto quell'insieme di suoni che
caratterizzano il panorama sonoro di una
passeggiata al parco ma quel suono
Contiene anche altre informazioni ad
esempio informazioni più tecniche come
la frequenza la melodia e il ritmo
quindi non abbiamo bisogno di essere
nerd per capire che un suono contiene
tante informazioni Quante la pagina di
un libro
Finora abbiamo visto che i dati sono
ovunque dei risultati elettorali al
video del tuo gatto però abbiamo anche
visto che questi dati possono essere
anche immagini possono essere anche
suoni e parole iniziamo appunto dalle
parole Questa è una pagina di un
giornale britannico del XIX secolo e
come potete vedere è piena di parole ma
questa anche è anche uno dei dataset più
interessanti a cui abbia mai lavorato
proprio così perché qualche anno fa la
British Library a Londra mi ha
commissionato la creazione di due
visualizzazioni di dati per una mostra
sulle notizie del diciannovesimo Secolo
e la British Library è un enorme
archivio di giornali di quotidiani che a
digitalizzato raccogliendo una marea di
dati
lo scopo di quella mostra era quello di
reimmaginare gli aspetti della vita del
XIX secolo attraverso le parole raccolte
in questi giornali e una delle opere
commissionate era quelle di raccontare
la guerra di Crimea del XIX secolo
secondo attraverso le parole usate dai
giornalisti per raccontare questo fatto
e questa è la visualizzazione che ho
creato ci sono tre anelli ognuno per
ogni anno della guerra e ogni anello
mostra le 50 parole più frequenti tratte
da una selezione dei giornali dell'epoca
e queste parole Noi ci dicono un
tantissime storie ad esempio nel 1855 la
parola pace viene citata 233 volte quasi
pari alla parola attacco e adesso ci
sembrano numeri bassi però i tempi non
c'erano né Facebook né Twitter però
queste parole ci raccontano anche altre
storie come ad esempio la nazionalità
degli eserciti coinvolti gli avanzamenti
militari e soprattutto la tragica
perdita di vite umane e per la prima
volta queste storie è proprio con queste
parole entrano nelle case dei cittadini
britannici soprattutto anche grazie alla
formazione di una nuova figura
professionale quella del corrispondente
ora i purisserà statistica staranno
scioccati perché questa visualizzazione
non usa dati numerici e non usa i famosi
grafici a torta grafici a barre ma
Seguitemi Perché il mio lavoro Mette in
discussione l'ipotesi Su quale
vocabolario visivo appartenga al mondo e
dell'arte rispetto a quello della
statistica
e ritornando al suono come dato oggi
voglio parlarvi di un'idea un'idea che
mi ha aiutato a usare il suono per
creare una fotografia perduta
quando qualche anno fa è mancato mio
padre stavo cercando una fotografia e
come penso sia comune fra le fotografie
dei nostri cari tutti noi abbiamo una
fotografia preferita ebbene la mia
fotografia preferita è andata persa non
l'ho mai più ritrovata Quindi nonostante
la frustrazione per l'assenza di questa
fotografia ho riflettuto sul fatto che
quando si lavora con i dati è molto
comune non trovare abbastanza dati per
la propria ricerca quindi sentirsi
bloccati
quindi ho riflettuto sul fatto che
l'assenza di dati è un dato Si ok a
direte voi però come fai a visualizzare
i dati se non li hai Beh recentemente
leggendo un libro mi sono imbattuta in
una parola molto interessante questa
parola è sublimazione
e la sublimazione è una teoria
sviluppata da Freud secondo la quale da
forma ai sentimenti inconsci attraverso
narrazione e rappresentazioni è il mondo
dell'Arte è pieno di esempi di
sublimazione ve ne mostro un esempio
questo è un ritratto che nel 1866
Cézanne realizza di suo padre il padre
di Cézanne era un banchiere non aveva
mai provato la carriera artistica del
figlio quindi stai usando decide di
ritrarre il padre sublimando il
sentimento di tensione nei suoi
confronti E come lo ritraeva seduto un
po' in bilico scomodo su questa poltrona
mentre legge un giornale che
probabilmente odiava e per di più alle
sue spalle aggiunge un proprio dipinto
una dichiarazione della propria
realizzazione artistica
questo quadro quindi combina l'amore di
Cézanne per il proprio padre ma comunica
anche l'attenzione del loro rapporto
vi ricordate la storia della mia
fotografia perduta e ho anche di
quell'archivio di dati di suoni che io
ho costruito nel corso degli anni Beh
leggendo questa storia ho pensato
posso usare questa teoria della
sublimazione per ricreare la mia
fotografia perduta Io sono data Artist
per me i dati sono un po' come gli
inchiostri e pennelli che se sanno usava
per i suoi dipinti
e nella mia pratica artistica i suoni
sono i miei dati uso questi audio per
ricostruire immagini che raccontano una
storia o fissano un momento proprio come
una fotografia e quella fotografia
perduta io l'ho ricreata l'ho ricreata
attraverso le voci e i dati
Questa è la fotografia che ho ricreato
ho deciso di usare le registrazioni
vocali di mio padre che ho trovato
online tratte da due tolche Che
individualmente abbiamo fatto a distanza
di anni ho scaricato questi audio e li
ho elaborati al computer dopo ore e ore
passate al computer o esportato le
nostre voci che una volta rappresentate
visivamente convergono in queste due
cerchi uniti
e questa visualizzazione di dati
quest'opera di un metro per un metro in
gergo si chiama driven by Deta Che vuol
dire guidata dai dati perché qui ogni
dettaglio non è casuale ad esempio i
cerchi rappresentano la
rappresentazione del grafica dell'onda
sonora delle nostre voci
il colore ad esempio è stato campionato
da una fotografia del mare da cui
estratto proprio questa sfumatura di blu
ben precisa e il dettaglio delle onde
sonore come potete vedere un cerchio è
più dettagliato e l'altro un po' meno
varia in base alla lunghezza dell'audio
registrato
quindi cosa mi ha insegnato questo
lavoro che i dati non si limitano i
numeri che noi possiamo raccontare
storie guidate dai dati perché i dati
possono essere anche parole suoni
fotografie immagini anche Feed di social
media
E ho anche imparato che l'assenza di
dati è un dato e la loro assenza ci
racconta una storia quindi quando non
troviamo dati per la nostra ricerca non
disperiamoci troppo
così Come un pittore usainchiostri e
pennelli per realizzare un dipinto io
uso i dati qualsiasi tipo di dati dei
numeri ai suoni per mostrare e
raccontare storie o volte anche solo per
creare una fotografia perduta Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]